forget about fantastic beasts this time
around we're trying to find fantastic
reviews and they're harder to come by
than you might think correct three
points to hufflepuff fantastic beasts
the secrets of dumbledore is the third
film in the wizarding world prequel
series directed by harry potter veteran
david yates it picks up several years
after the events of 2018's fantastic
feasts the crimes of grindelwald the new
installment follows professor albus
dumbledore as he enlists magiszuologist
newt scamander to help him fight against
gellert grindelwald the dark wizard
seeking out control of the wizarding
world jk rowling who wrote the first two
films returned as a screenwriter
although this time she teamed up with
steve cloves aka the writer of all but
one of the harry potter films the harry
potter series is one of the most
successful franchises of all time but
the fantastic beasts movie spin-offs
haven't quite seen the same success with
audiences or critics the first film in
the prequel series 2016's fantastic
beasts and where to find them fared
pretty well with its reviews earning
itself a 74 score on rotten tomatoes
however the follow-up film fantastic
beasts the crimes of grindelwald didn't
even come close to achieving the same
kind of success with viewers widely
derided for its overstuffed screenplay
it holds a rotten tomatoes rating of
just 36 percent
so how does the upcoming secrets of
dumbledore compare to its predecessors
when it comes to critical consensus well
as of the making of this video it falls
squarely in the middle at a 62 score on
the tomato meter some reviews are okay
with it and some really aren't here's a
rundown of what these divided critics
think things are not quite what they
appear
despite the secrets of dumbledore
nabbing a better tomato meter score than
its 2018 predecessor many critics were
still not impressed with the latest
effort of the franchise speaking for
many of the critics who didn't love the
film entertainment weekly declared that
the third time is not quite the charm
some critics found that the film lacked
focus and felt generally all over the
place one of the critics kate urbland of
indy wire wrote that the film offers an
unwieldy mostly unsettling mashup of
adult themes and childish whimsy made
still more inscrutable by too many
subplots too many characters and a tone
that fears wildly off course at every
possible turn
meanwhile charles bramasko of polygon
first suggests the series should have
called it quits after the last movie
before pointing out that newt who began
the series as the protagonist is barely
involved in what's become the actual
plot of this series he wrote
newt's convoluted anticlimactic quest to
secure and deliver his precious cargo
lacks the delighted curiosity that lent
the first fantastic beasts a much-needed
bump in charm finally in a scathing
review siddhant adlaka of ign wrote
there are two more entries planned but
ending the harry potter spin-off here
would be a mercy there's nothing
fantastic about the new movie the story
is dull the characters are duller
it's not all bad though though the
review for entertainment weekly implied
the film missed the mark overall writer
leah greenblatt still found some merit
to the movie she concluded her review on
the note that the secrets of dumbledore
is a major step up from its predecessor
deeming it quote nimbler and sweeter and
more cohesive in its storyline
greenblatt also noted that this time
around the cast are given more room to
explore the stakes their characters face
instead of just shuttling along from
scene to scene on the subject of the
acting peter de bruges of variety noted
that mass mickelson is better suited for
the character of gellert grindelwald
than johnny depp who played the
character in the previous film de bruges
wrote that mikkelsen comes off favorably
as a more grounded less cartoonishly
menacing version of the character he
also gave credit to the screenplay which
he found far more focused and easier to
follow than the last one in one of the
most positive reviews four out of five
stars linda merrick of the jewish
chronicle called it a welcome return to
form and gave special praise to the
performances of law and mickelson she
summed up the movie by saying gates
rolling in cloves have given us an
engaging story peppered throughout with
some funny heartfelt and exciting action
sequences what side of the divide will
you be on the only way to find out is to
see the movie for yourself when
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore premieres in theaters on
april 15th who wouldn't like our chances
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]